problema número 125 estamos en la página
288 el problema dice lo siguiente dice
que r y s y s son enteros positivos
enteros positivos
positivos y lo que queremos determinar
es cierre entre s s entero si r
/ s es entero o sea básicamente si se
divide a r entero
ok vamos a ver qué información nos dan
en el inciso 1 nos dicen que cada factor
de ese también es un factor de r cada
factor de s
cada factor de s es factor factor de r
de r ok pues esto está fácil verdad
todos o sea quién es el factor más
grandote de ese el factor más grandote
de ese pues es ese entonces eso nos dice
que ese es factor de r pero si ese es
factor de r eso justo quiere decir que
ese divide a r vale y entonces tenemos
que r entre s es entero el inciso a es
suficiente para responder esta pregunta
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 el 2 es
muy parecido dice cada factor primo
primo
primo de ese de ese es factor es también
un factor es factor factor primo
de r entonces se parece mucho a la de
arriba pero esta no va a ser cierta
verdad de hecho es fácil buscar un
contraejemplo en el cual cada factor de
ese el factor primo de ese es un factor
primo de r pero esto de aquí no queda
entero por ejemplo podemos tomar digamos
r&r iguala a 6 que es igual a 2 por 3 y
ese igual a 4
que es igual a 2 por 2 2 por 2 entonces
cada factor primo de s que sólo son los
dos pues también es factor de r vale
este 12 este 2 ok entonces cada factor
primo de ese factor primo de r pero r
entre s r entre s es igual a 6 cuartos
que es 3 medios
que es igual a 1.5 entonces aquí pues no
fue entero pero también podemos dar un
ejemplo en donde se enteró por ejemplo
si r es igual a 2 por 2 x 2 y s es igual
a 2 por 2
o sea cierres 8 y ese es 48 entre 4 nos
queda 2 perdón si nos queda 2 84 nos
queda 2 y aquí sí nos queda entero muy
bien entonces ésta de acá no es
información suficiente para saber si
éste es entero vamos al problema bueno
primero déjame ponerle que la respuesta
es
y vamos al problema 126 126 muy bien en
el problema 126 nos dicen que z a la n
es igual a 1 y lo que nos piden
determinar es el valor de z
antes de ver las opciones pensemos un
poco qué tiene que suceder para que se
está a la n s a
uno a ver pues cualquier número elevado
a la cero x a la cero es igual a 1 por
ejemplo 10 a la 0 es igual a 18 126 a la
0 es igual a 1 vale esta es una
posibilidad y la otra posibilidad es que
x otro zeta ceta sea igual a 1 o que sea
menos 1 y que en ese a para vale bueno
vamos a ver qué nos dicen las opciones
número uno
nos dicen que n es distinto de cero
distinto de 0 nos dicen que es distinto
de 0 y entero
entero entero
ok 100 es distinto de 0 y entero pues
entonces estamos descartando estas ya
cada verdad ya no podemos utilizar algo
a la 0 entonces pues la un las únicas
posibilidades para zetas serían 1 o
menos 1 otra vez a menos que estemos en
los complejos en los números complejos
pero bueno ahorita no nos importan
porque no se evalúan en este examen
entonces z es 1 o menos 1 pero todavía
no podemos determinar el valor de z
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 nos dicen z mayor que 0 pues
esto es justo lo que necesitamos
agregarle a este ya cada verdad si z es
mayor que 0 nada más sin la información
del inciso 1 pues pudiéramos tener cosas
del estilo 10 a la 0 o 126 a la 0 y ahí
no podríamos determinar el valor de z
pero combinándolo con el inciso 1 acepta
sólo le queda hacer 1 o menos 1 pero no
es menos 1 porque es mayor que 0 y
entonces z sería 1
z sería 1 entonces por separado nos
sirven pero en conjunto si sirven para
responder la pregunta la respuesta sería
sí muy bien vamos ahora al problema 127
127 muy bien nos ponen una expresión un
poco fea que le llaman ese ese haber ese
es igual a 12 entre n
/
1 / x + 2 / 3x y lo que nos piden
determinar bueno nos dicen que x n es
distinto de 0 y lo que nos piden
determinar es el valor de s ok así está
muy feo es de verdad déjame
simplificarlo un poco haciendo la suma
de fracciones aquí abajo el denominador
común sería 3x entonces nos quedaría s
es igual a 12 entre n dividido entre 3
entre 3 x más 2 entre 3x y eso sería
igual a 2 entre n dividido entre 5 entre
3x que se puede simplificar más tenemos
que multiplicar este por este sería
igual a 6x dividido entre entre este por
este 5 n vale entonces necesitamos
determinar el valor de esta expresión de
acá esto está mucho más y mucho menos
espantoso verdad bueno vamos a ver qué
opciones nos dan en el inciso 1 nos
dicen que x es igual a 12 n si sabemos
que x es igual a 12 n podemos
sustituirlo aquí y nos quedaría 6 por 2
por n dividido entre 5 n
n se cancela con n y nos queda 12
quintos y esto ya es un numerito
entonces esta información si fue
suficiente y en el inciso 2 lo que nos
dicen es que n es igual a un medio pero
si es igual a un medio no pasa nada
verdad aunque sustituyamos aquí aunque
sustituyamos n igual a un medio tenemos
6x entre cinco medios que sería 12 x
entre 5 que todavía no es un número no
sabemos nada acerca de x entonces no
podemos responder la pregunta y esta
condición de x n distinto de 0
ah pues simplemente es para poder
dividir entre n y / x vale bueno
entonces la respuesta es que el inciso 1
si de información suficiente pero el
inciso 2 no y por lo tanto la respuesta
sería y la respuesta sería ah
nos queda tiempo para hacer uno más
déjame bajar un poco voy a tomar el
color verde y le pongo 128 128 128 es
una potencia de 2 bueno a ver en el 128
nos dicen que x es un entero
x es entero
pero y lo que queremos determinar es si
x por valor absoluto de x es menor que 2
a la x
esta de aquí es la pregunta bueno a ver
veamos qué sucede en el inciso 1 lo que
nos dicen es que x es menor que 0 x es
menor que 0
a ver si x es menor que 0 este número de
aquí es negativo este de aquí es
positivo negativo x positivo da negativo
entonces aquí nos quedaría al lado
izquierdo algo negativo
negativo y queremos ver si eso es menor
que 2 a la x pero 2 a la x sin importar
que x pongamos que nos va a quedar algo
positivo si sea si ponemos x igual a 4
pues queda 16 si ponemos x igual a un
medio nos queda a raíz de 2 a lo mejor
es dices bueno no podemos poner un medio
porque x es entero pero bueno intentamos
poner menos 12 a la menos 1 es un medio
que sigue siendo positivo 2 a la
cualquier número a la cualquier entero
nos da una cosa positiva entonces del
lado derecho tenemos algo positivo y
algo positivo le gana a algo negativo
entonces esta información de aquí es
suficiente para responder la pregunta y
en el inciso 2
nos dicen que x es igual a menos 10 pues
éste está súper fácil verdad si sabemos
que x es igual a menos 10 claro que
podemos responder esta pregunta es más
hasta vamos a hacerlo no tendríamos que
hacerlo pero bueno nos queda menos 10
por el valor absoluto de menos 10 que es
10 y tenemos que ver si eso es menor que
2 a la menos 10 y esto si sucede de
verdad 2 a la menos 10 es igual a 1
entre 1024 que es una cosa positiva y de
este lado tenemos menos 100 menos 100
que es una cosa negativa entonces es el
mismo argumento de aquí arriba verdad al
lado izquierdo siempre tenemos algo
negativo al derecho algo en el derecho
algo positivo vale entonces si esta de
aquí también es suficiente entonces la
respuesta
de muy bien le dejamos hasta aquí y
continuamos en el próximo vídeo